[Music]
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking thrones now that episode
6 is officially released there is
something I want to discuss specifically
before I make my review video this
episode was released very early thanks
to HBO Spain and I know some of you want
to talk about how the night king got
those big chains to pull this ariane out
of the lake or why the night king didn't
just kill drove on instead but saved
those questions for my review video
tomorrow because i would rather hear
your opinion on this subject first i
have seen this episode a few times now
and it has allowed me to take some extra
time to think about this topic but i'm
going to be honest would be right up
front I still don't have the perfect
answer for this but I want to go over
some of the options still now that the
night king has his own dragon the
question is how can it be killed I need
some feedback from you on this one so
let me know how you think the dragon can
be stopped the answer might seem obvious
but I don't think it's going to be as
clear as it may seem in order to kill
the night King's Dragon it may take
something we haven't seen done before
but I will let you be the judge before
we try and figure out how the dragon can
be killed you first have to figure out
what kind of dragon it is now the night
King has two very different types of
soldiers in his army you have the whites
which are at the very lowest tier of the
army basically the foot soldiers the
whites are created by the night king by
raising the dead just like we saw at
hardhome when he lifted his arms up in
the air and all the dead people opened
their eyes and stood back up the whites
typically look like corpses or skeletons
they can be killed by using fire but for
some reason they changed it this season
and now they can be killed with
dragonglass too but then you have the
White Walkers and these are the night
king strongest soldiers the White
Walkers were created by the night King
touching the cheek of Craster's sons the
White Walkers have superhuman strength
and they can only be killed by
dragonglass in Valyrian steel but the
night King also has Giants polar bears
and now he has a dragon when you go back
and look at how the night King brought
the dragon back from the dead he brought
bazarian back just like he did with
crashed her son's he did it by placing
his hand on the Dragons head so in my
opinion this makes the dragon a white
Walker basically it's the most powerful
way he can bring something
under his control or command which will
make this dragon even harder to kill if
he would have brought the dragon back by
raising his arms that would have been a
white dragon but since he touched it
it's a white Walker dragon since it has
the powers and weaknesses of a white
Walker then you should be able to kill
this dragon by using dragon glass or
Valyrian steel but then again you have
to think about how dragon glass and
Valyrian steel has made dragon glass is
a type of volcanic glass some people say
that dragon glass is made by dragon fire
while others say dragon glass is made
from the fires of the earth george RR
martin said that dragon glass has
magical properties and if dragon glass
is made by dragon's fire then it might
not be able to kill this Ariane since he
is a dragon himself but depending on
what the actual magical properties are
in it then maybe it still can kill him
if you put a dragon glass arrow tip
through vissarion's big blue eye then it
could potentially shatter him into a
thousand pieces of ice but what about
Valyrian steel Valyrian steel is also
called dragon steel and george RR martin
has also said himself that Valyrian
steel has magical properties - and they
are possibly forged by using dragon fire
now this is where it kind of gets tricky
for me because if it's the dragon's fire
that makes dragon glass and Valyrian
steel special then it might not be able
to kill a dragon even though it's a
white Walker dragon now but since they
also have magical properties in them
then that might be enough to kill the
knight Kings dragon if dragon glass or
Valyrian steel does work against
vissarion then they might have to make
it into some kind of projectile
something that can shoot at Vissarion
because I doubt they're ever going to be
able to get close enough to stab him you
could also look at this symbolically to
Daenerys named Vissarion after her
brother Viserys and she also named Rogan
after called Drogo since called Drogo
killed her brother Viserys then we may
need drove on to kill this Ariane and
this would make the whole day dragon
thing even more dramatic Daenerys may
have to kill her own dragon in order to
stop bazarian from killing her or her
other dragons or potentially everyone
but then again you have to think about
the strengths and weaknesses of the
Dragons most importantly a white Walker
dragon you might not be able to kill
this area on what fire
even if it's dragons fire we have seen
the White Walkers and the night King
walk right through fire before not only
did they walk through the fire but when
they did walk through it you could see
the fire actually died down
significantly
now obviously dragon fire is much more
powerful than regular fire but in this
episode the knight King actually walked
right through the dragon fire to near
the end of the episode the knight King
and John Snow had another stare down and
when the knight King walked forward he
stepped right through the dragon fire on
the ground as if it wasn't even there so
considering that I'm not so confident
that Viserion can be brought down with
any kind of fire I do have a tinfoil
idea though that's probably not likely
but I'm going to tell you about it
anyway in the books there is a horn
called dragon binder
you're on Greyjoy says this horn is
capable of binding a dragon to someone's
will which means by using this horn you
can control a dragon they never did
introduce this horn in the show but they
did introduce another horn in the show
and it was very brief but they did show
it back in season two some of the Nights
Watch was at the fist of the first men
in granting Sam more digging in the snow
and they uncovered a stash of dragon
glass and there was a horn many people
believe this was the Horn of winter and
many people also believed that this
would be the horn that would bring down
the wall but it was never mentioned or
showed again I have assumed Sam has had
this horn with him the entire time I was
hoping he would study it while he was at
the Citadel but he never did while he
was there the reason Sam left the
Citadel in episode 5 was because the
maesters didn't take brains warning very
serious brain said the dead were
marching to Eastwatch so Sam stole a
bunch of books and documents from the
Citadel and now he's heading north I
think if Sam still has that horn that he
found with the stash of dragonglass
perhaps they could use this horn as a
dragon binder someone could potentially
blow this horn and gain control of the
night Kings dragon or possibly blowing
the horn could cause it to shatter into
pieces of ice like we've seen the other
White Walkers do when they are beaten I
know that's some extra tin foil but I
had to throw that in there I think that
would be an interesting way they could
bring the horn back into the plot but
that's just me another way they can try
and kill this Ariane is by using where
wood you can make weapons out of the
weirwood trees as well
and the books there are several weapons
made from the wood from a weirwood tree
like bows and Spears and even arrows the
children of the forest used weirwood
bows and even blood Raven aka the
three-eyed Raven had a weirwood bow I
think this could potentially kill the
dragon the weirwood trees are obviously
very magical and powerful too
and if you made a big enough arrow out
of where wood and you shot it using a
scorpion and might be able to take the
dragon down especially if he was able to
put the arrow right through his eye but
then again you might just have to kill
the night king himself in order to stop
this ariane if you can kill the dragon
with dragonglass Valyrian steel where
what arrows buyer or a horn then you're
going to have to stop the night king
first and it should shut down his entire
army including Viserion I made a video
several months ago about how to defeat
the night king and one of the ideas I
had was if you kill the night king then
it should stop his whole army since he
is controlling them all if you can shut
off the night Kings brain or conscience
then it should shut down everything else
that he's controlling we actually saw an
example of this in episode 6 when Jon
Snow killed the white Walker when Jon
killed him almost all of the whites that
he had in his little group shut down too
when the White Walkers shattered from
the Valyrian steel the other White's
broke into pieces pretty much
simultaneously the characters noticed
this too so now they know if you can get
the puppetmaster and kill him then the
rest will fall to the night King might
not ride the dragon into every battle so
it might be easier to kill the night
king than it is the dragon you stopped
the night king you stopped the dragon
but obviously this is all easier said
than done it's going to be interesting
to see how things play out now that the
night king has his own ultimate weapon
I'm also curious to see how Danny's
mental stability is from here on out now
that she lost one of her own children it
would also be a tragedy if Daenerys had
to sacrifice herself in some way in
order to stop her own dragon from
killing everyone else that would be one
of those gut-punching twists if that
happened now that the night king has a
dragon things just got a hell of a lot
more interesting in my opinion he could
essentially fly right over top of the
wall if you wanted to when season 8
begins we should see the night king and
his entire army on the south side of the
wall
and when the other step foot on the soil
south of the wall the Great War will
have officially begun I don't know if
Jon Snow is going to be able to get the
support that he needs in time before the
night king makes his way down to
Winterfell Jon Snow better hope Cersei
eventually sends some kind of support in
season eight or else the mission to get
the white will have been for nothing
Viserion will have died for nothing
other than Danny just seeing the dead
for herself so I can't wait to see how
they plan on stopping the night king now
that he has Giants bears and a dragon
but comment down below with your
questions and thoughts I'm curious to
see what all of you have to say about
this I want to thank everyone for
watching tonight's video I really do
appreciate that and I will release a
full video about episode 6 tomorrow so I
hope you all come back for that one I
also want to thank all of you on patreon
thank you very much for the continued
support I will see you down in the
comment section bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]